موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
عقدت جلسه طريئه بمجلس الامن الدولي
لمناقشه ابعاد وتداعيات تفجير السد كخوفكا
جنوبيه اوكرانيا وحضر وكيلا من العام
للعوامل الانسانيه مما وصفه بعواقب وخيمه
وبعيده المدى لتدمير السد بالنسبه لالاف
الاشخاص في جنوب اوكرانيا هذا وتبادلت
اوكرانيا وروسيا الاتهامات
كافي منطقه خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا لتحقيق
مكاسب عسكريه وتعمل الجيش الاوكراني
للقوات الروسيه بتفجير السد بينما رد
الروس باتهام اوكرانيا بتفجيره باستخدام
راجمات الصواريخ
وعقاله السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مدينه
نوفا
التي تدفقت من السد اصبحت خارج السيطره
بعد ان غمرت عشرات البلدات
قلت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في
بيان انه لا يوجد اي خطر مباشر على سلامه
المحطه النوويه فيروجيا كما نفعل القائم
باعمال حاكم مقاطعه الموالي لروسيا وجود
اي تهديد لتشغيل المحطه اما امين مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني فقال اين التفجير
السد يشكل تهديدا لمحطه
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن وثائقه مسربه
لانه وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه علمت عبر وكاله في تجسس اوروبيه
ان قوات اوكرانيه خططت لتفجير خط نورل
ستريم الذي وقع في سبتمبر من العام الماضي
وقالت الصحيفه
لهجوم سري على نورثرين في بحر البلطيق
واضافت الصحيفه ان المعلومات الاستخباريه
الالمانيه تكشف تشابه التفاصيل بين المخطط
والتنفيذ هذا وقد امتنعت واشنطن عن
التعليق واكدت انها بانتظار التحقيقات
كشف الحرس الثوري والايراني عن صاروخ فرط
صوتي اطلق عليه اسم فتاح بحضور الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي وعشرته
قادرون على الوصول الى سرعه عاليه
والتحليق داخل وخارج الغلاف الجوي ويصل
مداه الى
1400 كم
في الاثناء قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين امير عبد الهيان في تغريده على تويتر
ان قوه الرضع الايرانيه ضمان لاستقرار
الامن والسلام في المنطقه
قال له منسق والاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان اداره
الرئيس بايدن حازمه في التصدي لبرنامج
طيران لصواريخ الباليستيه في الاثناء فرضت
وزاره الخزنه الامريكيه عقوبات جديده
تستهدف برنامج ايران الصاروخي
قال ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربي ان
اجتماعات لجنه 6 + 6 المعنيه باعداد
القوانين الانتخابيه في ليبيا والتي جرت
في مدينه بوزنيقه في المغرب مكنت من
الوصول الى توافقات مهمه فيما يخص
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه واضافها
بريطانيا لم تكن سهله وان الانتخابات
القادمه
ستحسم مساله الشرعيه قال ان توافقات
بوزنيقه تحتاج الى مواكبه واراده سياسيه
حقيقيه لتكون لتوافقات امكانيه للتطبيق
على ارض الواقع
انتهى الموجه زي لما كنتم قامت اوقاتكم
بكل خير
[موسيقى]